en este vídeo quiero ver un tema muy
importante que tiene que ver bastante
con lo que vimos en el vídeo pasado en
este vídeo quiero ver el tema de
completando el cuadrado y tú seguramente
te estás preguntando a qué se refiere
sal con completando el cuadrado y bueno
la respuesta es la siguiente si te
acuerdas en los vídeos pasados veíamos
expresiones de este estilo x cuadrada
vamos a tomar un ejemplo y de este
ejemplo vamos a partir entonces tomemos
la ecuación cuadrática x cuadrada menos
4x es igual a 5x cuadrada déjenme
escribirlo por aquí x cuadrado menos 4x
voy a dejar un espacio ahorita van a ver
por qué y esto es igual así y este
espacio que estoy dejando aquí es un
espacio muy importante para ver este
tema porque este tema se llama
completando el cuadrado perfecto y es
que la idea que hay detrás es justo lo
que veíamos en el vídeo pasado voy a
intentar que la parte izquierda de esta
ecuación sea un binomio cuadrado
perfecto y la idea es que usemos todo
nuestro ingenio para que la parte
izquierda de esta ecuación
lo creemos un binomio al cuadrado
perfecto sumando algo o restando algo
utilizando nuestra imaginación para que
lleguemos a un binomio al cuadrado
perfecto es decir atrás lo que voy es
algo de la forma x menos a elevado al
cuadrado o x más ha elevado al cuadrado
y bueno seguramente no me entiendes nada
así que voy a escribir lo mejor por aquí
para que te vaya quedando un poco más
claro yo quiero que x cuadrada menos 4 x
más álbum sea igual a x menos a elevado
al cuadrado es decir si yo elevó este
binomio al cuadrado perfecto que me
quedarían pues me queda el cuadrado del
primero menos dos veces el primero por
el segundo más el cuadrado del segundo
esta es la fórmula clásica del binomio
cuadrado perfecto entonces sigue aquí
tengo menos 4x perdón perdón aquí me
faltaba una x si yo aquí tengo menos 4x
voy a suponer que esto es dos veces a x
y esto es porque aquí quiero encontrar
el cuadrado del segundo si yo encuentro
el cuadrado del segundo entonces ya
puedo suponer que esto es un binomio el
cuadrado perfecto y bueno sin menos 4x
es igualdad 2x entonces a debe de ser
menos
porque date cuenta menos 2 x 2 es menos
4 y x x me queda menos 4x y si a vale
menos 2 entonces a cuadrada vale 4 atrás
de esa idea voy y bueno tal vez existe
un poco de bolas con todo esto que estoy
diciendo pero fíjate agarramos el
término que tienen solamente la equis
elevado a la primera potencia nos
fijamos en el coeficiente que está al
lado de la equis que es menos 4 le
sacamos la mitad la mitad va a ser menos
dos gigantes llegan lo mismo a es igual
a menos dos y después lo elevamos al
cuadrado menos dos al cuadrado es lo
mismo que 4 positivo y como lo que me
hace falta es un 4 positivo entonces
pongo aquí el 4 en esta ecuación pero
ojo ten cuidado porque cuando yo agrego
4 de un lado de la ecuación entonces del
otro lado de la ecuación tengo que hacer
lo mismo eso lo vimos en los primeros
vídeos hablando de este tema si yo hago
algo de un lado de la ecuación el otro
lado de la ecuación tiene que sufrir el
mismo cambio aquí agregué 4 entonces en
el lado derecho me va a quedar 5 más 4 y
bueno déjame escribir esto otra vez aquí
abajo para que no te vayas perdiendo de
qué es lo que estamos buscando
entonces déjenme cambio de color y ahora
si esto de aquí es lo mismo que x
cuadrada menos 4 x + 4 y esto va a ser
igual a 54 ya sabemos cuánto es 54 es 9
y bueno yo agregue un 4 de ambos lados
de la ecuación porque yo lo que quería
es que esta parte izquierda de mi
ecuación sea un binomio al cuadrado
perfecto y qué creés ya lo es porque
tengo dos números que multiplicados me
den 4 y que sumados me den de los 4 pues
es x 2 x x menos 2 es justo como lo
veíamos en el vídeo pasado que hicimos
de este mismo tema me queda x menos 2
por x menos 2 es igual a 9 o dicho de
otra manera
x minutos al cuadrado es igual a 9 y te
acuerdas que hacíamos sacábamos raíz de
ambos lados de la ecuación
entonces me queda x menos 2 es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de 9 que es más menos 3
y después pasó al menos 2 del otro lado
de la ecuación con signo contrario me
queda que x es igualdad 2 más menos 3 o
dicho otra manera la primera raíz me
queda dos más tres los cuales 5x es
igual a 5 y la segunda raíz me queda dos
menos 3 lo cual me da menos 1 y así ya
consigo mis 2
y cesc que eran necesarias para tener
esta ecuación de segundo grado pero en
esta ocasión utilizamos el método de
completando el cuadrado perfecto vamos a
ver como lo hacíamos en las ocasiones
pasadas si te acuerdas al principio lo
que sigamos será pasar todo lo que
estaba del lado derecho de la ecuación
del otro lado entonces me quedaría x
cuadrada menos 4 x menos 5 igual a 0 y
después buscaba dos números que
multiplicados me dieran menos 5 y que
sumados me dieran menos 4 y si lo
pensamos un poquito me va a dar x menos
5 por x más 1 menos 5 x más 1 me da
menos 5 y menos cinco más uno me da
menos 4 y de aquí ya tengo mis 2 raíces
en mi primera raíz es 5 o mi segunda
raíces menos 1 y llegamos a lo mismo
solamente que en esta ocasión estamos
utilizando un nuevo método el método de
completando el binomio al cuadrado
perfecto y este método es muy importante
y nos va a servir bastante para
demostrar la fórmula general de segundo
grado parece ser que este método está
bastante bastante bien así que vamos a
intentar hacer otro ejercicio tal vez un
poco más general para reafirmar todo lo
que acabamos de ver y que entiendas un
poco mejor de lo que te estoy hablando
al final si hacemos
los ejercicios te va a quedar muy claro
cómo utilizar este método así que vamos
a tomarme la ecuación 10 x cuadrada
menos 30 x menos 8 igual a 0 10 x
cuadrada menos 30 x menos 8 igual a 0 y
lo primero que te das cuenta es que
tenemos un 10 en un principio y de hecho
que todo es divisible entre dos así que
vamos de una vez a dividir todo esto
entre 2 que me va a quedar 10 entre 2
menos 30 entre 2 menos 8 entre 2 y 0
entre 2 y esto me va a quedar 5 x
cuadrado menos 15 x menos 4 esto es
igual a 0 y bueno si lo que queremos es
factorizar esta ecuación te vas a dar
cuenta que no es nada sencillo de
factorizar pues tenemos el principio 15
que parece bastante rebelde y que no nos
va a dejar factorizar este trinomio de
una manera sencilla entonces tal vez se
te ocurra a dividir todo entre 5 para
quitarnos ese problema entonces vamos a
dividir todo entre 5 y vamos a ver aquí
llegamos y bueno la idea que hay detrás
es quitar este 5 de un principio para
que intentes ver si podemos factorizar
o acaso si no sabemos factorizar esto
sería mucho mejor utilizar lo que ya
aprendimos es decir el método de
computar el cuadrado perfecto entonces
voy a dividir todo entre 5 y me queda
cinco entre 51 entonces es x cuadrada
después 15 entre 5 es 3 me queda menos
3x y después menos 4 entre 5 que me
quedan menos cuatro quintos igual a cero
entre 5 que es cero siempre podemos
dividir entre 5 o entre el número que
esté al lado de x cuadrada para que me
quede 1 y cuando intentes utilizar este
método de completando el cuadrado te
aconsejo que siempre hagas esto pero
aquí tengo un loco menos cuatro quintos
que no me deja factorizar esta expresión
y date cuenta que esta ecuación no es
nada fácil de factorizar imagínate
buscar dos números que multiplicados me
den menos cuatro quintos y que sumados
me den menos tres así que déjame
escribirlo para que recuerde siempre que
esto no está nada fácil de actualizar
entonces es bastante difícil de
factorizar esta expresión que yo tengo
aquí entonces para resolver este
problema hay que buscarle por otros
métodos y el método que vamos a ver es
otra vez completando el cuadrado
perfecto
los profesores que trabajan el completar
el binomio cuadrado perfecto de otra
manera distinta a mí lo completan desde
aquí sin pasar este menos cuatro quintos
del otro lado de la ecuación sin embargo
a mí me gusta pasarlo de una vez del
otro lado de la ecuación ya mí se me
hace mucho más sencillo los dos métodos
son correctos pero a mí este método se
nos facilita un poco más entonces x
cuadrada menos 3 x me va a quedar igual
porque después tengo menos cuatro
quintos más cuatro quintos lo cual se
cancela me queda cero voy a dejar un
espacio y después del otro lado me queda
cuatro quintos esto es justo lo que
estábamos viendo hace rato en la otra
pantalla y el procedimiento nos decía
que había que fijarnos en este menos 3 x
te acuerdas y decíamos vamos a fijarnos
en el coeficiente de menos 3x que es
menos 3 ya este número que tenemos aquí
voy a dividirlo entre 2 para sacar el
valor de a entonces es igual a menos 3
entre 2 cuanto menos tres entre dos
buenos exacto voy a ponerlos y menos 3
entre 2 y después lo que hago es elevar
al cuadrado recuerda que tras lo que voy
es de hacer que esto sea un binomio al
cuadrado perfecto y el cuadrado de menos
tres medios
es nueve cuartos cuadrados de menos 39
cuadrado de dos es cuatro y entonces voy
a suponer que este de aquí es un binomio
cuadrado perfecto pero no tan rápido no
tan rápido no tan rápido aquí lo que nos
falta es un marley del otro lado nueve
cuartos nunca olvides que lo que hacemos
de un lado de la ecuación lo vamos a
hacer también del otro lado de la
ecuación para que se mantenga
equilibrada la balanza y entonces me
queda x cuadrada menos 3 x + 9 cuartos
voy a ponerlo esto tal cual y voy a
hacer primero la operación que tengo
aquí cuatro quintos es lo mismo que voy
a multiplicar todo por 4 me quedan 4 por
4 16 y 5 por 4 20 16 sobre 20 la idea es
buscar el denominador común que es 20 y
entonces ahora voy a multiplicar nueve
cuartos por 5 sobre 5 es decir 45 sobre
20 45 sobre 20 y ahora cuánto es 16 más
45 sé que esto suena un poco enredado
pero es justo lo más divertido de
completar el cuadrado perfecto no
siempre es tan rápido pero funciona para
todas las cuestiones de segundo grado y
16 más 45 55 61 61 sobre b
bueno dejen de escribirlo otra vez todo
aquí abajo para que vean hasta dónde
vamos x cuadrada menos 3 x más 9 cuartos
es igual a 61 sobre 20 hasta aquí vamos
bien ahora fíjense en la parte izquierda
de esta ecuación si te das cuenta x
cuadrada menos 3 x más nueve cuartos es
un binomio el cuadrado perfecto justo lo
que hicimos lo completa el cuadrado y me
queda x menos tres medios elevado al
cuadrado si te das cuenta 2 x menos 3
medios es lo mismo que menos tres y tres
medios elevado al cuadrado me da nueve
cuartos y esto es igual a 61 sobre 20 y
bueno ahora si ya tengo justo lo que
hemos visto en varios vídeos lo que
tengo que hacer es pasar del otro lado
este cuadrado y lo voy a pasar como raíz
y entonces del lado izquierdo me queda x
menos 3 medios y del lado derecho me
queda más menos la raíz cuadrada de 61
sobre 20 si te das cuenta en 61 ni 20
tienen raíz cuadrada raíz cuadrada
exacta porque si tienen raíz cuadrada
pero son números irracionales entonces
solamente lo voy a dejar así y ahora voy
a pasar el otro lado el 3 medios me va a
quedar tres medios positivos más menos
las raíces
y 1 sobre 20 y ya con esto tengo mis dos
soluciones tengo que mi primera solución
es tres medios más la raíz de 61 sobre
20 y que mi segunda raíces 3 medios
menos la raíz de 61 sobre 20 es más
vamos a sacar la calculadora y vamos a
hacerlo voy a borrar todo esto que tengo
aquí es una gráfica que tenía de otro
ejercicio y ahora sí cuánto estrés
medios déjenme ponerlo 3 sobre 2 a 3
medios le voy a sumar la raíz cuadrada
de una división la raíz cuadrada de 61
sobre 20
cierro paréntesis y ahora si esto va a
ser igual a mi primera raíces 3.24 64 24
91 y 3.24 64 y eso lo podemos aproximar
más a 3.24 6 entonces esto es
aproximadamente 3.24 6 o en su dado caso
la otra raíz cuanto me va a salir pues
es esto mismo solamente que consignó
menos en medio entonces voy a copiar
toda la pantalla y lo que voy a hacer
el signo menos aquí en medio entonces me
voy a ir para acá
jajaja estrés no trampa para hacer menos
tiempo aquí le pongo signo de menos y le
pongo igual y esto me da menos punto 24
6 entonces vamos a escribirlo - punto 24
60 punto 24 6 y ya con esto tengo las
dos raíces de este ejercicio que quería
resolver si te das cuenta y vamos a
intentar probarlo a ver si realmente
tenemos la razón así que tengo x
cuadrada menos 3 x menos cuatro quintos
igual a cero y voy a sustituir se me
ocurre mejor la segunda opción porque es
la que tengo guardada aquí como
respuesta si yo le pongo respuesta o
answer entonces voy a obtener el valor
que teníamos aquí arriba entonces es
esta x elevada al cuadrado menos tres
veces esta misma x es decir menos tres
veces la respuesta ya esto le tengo que
restar menos cuatro quintos menos cuatro
sobre cinco y entonces esto va a ser
igual am y bueno me da un valor muy
cercano a cero casi
y es que cuando yo pongo este número
aquí en la calculadora tengo un número
irracional que es infinito imagínense
hacer una operación infinita pues la
calculadora nunca acabaría y por lo
tanto redondea el resultado y cuando le
pongo que me calculé esta operación
entonces me calcula un redondeo y por
eso me salió uno por diez a la menos 14
es decir 0.000 000 son 13 ceros y al
final 11 o sea muy pero muy pero muy
pequeño es casi cero pero es un valor
muy pequeño y no me salió cero porque la
calculadora está redondeando mi
resultado así que bueno ya con esto
estamos preparados para ver la fórmula
general de segundo grado lo cual me va a
servir para resolver cualquier ecuación
de segundo grado así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo